welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 15 and
we're gonna learn the productivity hacks
of billionaires
enjoy
[Music]
you're running you're ceo of two
companies you're chairman of solarcity
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep uh yeah
sometimes not enough
sleep is really great uh because because
if
i find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm i'm quite grumpy um
i mean obviously i think most people are
that way and
and also um like i try to sort of figure
out what's the
right amount of sleep because like i
found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it
i would get less done because
my mental acuity would be affected
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours on average per night
um that's not too bad yeah right and any
other tips
on average though any other tips on just
managing to run two companies
simultaneously i mean do you do you find
i mean i know you're up here monday
tuesday is it
all tesla when you're up in silicon
valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a sort of
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email
during interstitial periods like you're
in a car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere
you can do email practically when you're
awake um
and uh and so that's really helpful to
have
email for spacex and tesla integrated
on my phone um and then
uh and then it's just you have to
apply a lot of hours to actual working
actually working so
the way i generally do it is i'll be
working at spacex on monday and then
monday night flight to the bay area
spent tuesday and wednesday at the bay
area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night spend thursday and
friday
at spacex um in in
the last several months then i would fly
back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
or spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex
my view is i don't even like the phrase
work-life balance i think it's
misleading i like the phrase work life
harmony
because i know that if i
am energized at work happy at work
feeling like i'm adding value
part of a team whatever energizes you
that makes me better at home it makes me
a better husband
a better father and likewise if i'm
happy at home
it makes me a better employee a better
boss
all the things it's not about it's not
primarily about there may be crunch
periods where it's about the number of
hours in the week
but that that's not the most that's not
the real thing
usually it's about do you have energy
and is the
is your work depriving you of energy or
is your work
generating energy for you and you know
there are people
everybody in this room knows people you
who fall into these two camps
you're in a meeting and the person comes
in the room some people come into the
meeting
and they add energy to the meeting other
people come to the meeting
and the whole meeting just deflates and
those people just
they they drain energy from the meeting
and you have to decide which of those
kinds of people you're going to be
are you going to add energy um and the
same thing at home
and the same thing at home and it's so
it's a wheel it's a cycle it's a
flywheel it's a circle
it's not a balance because of balance
that's why that metaphor is so dangerous
because it implies there's a strict
trade-off
and you could be out of work have all
the time for your family in the world
but really depressed and demoralized
about your work situation
and your family wouldn't want to be
anywhere near you they would wish you
would take a vacation from them
and so it's not about the number of
hours not primarily i suppose if you
went crazy with you know 100 hours a
week or something
yeah maybe right maybe there are limits
and they probably
i've never had a problem um and i think
it's because
both sides of my life give me energy and
that's what i would recommend that's
what i do recommend to interns and execs
as a person as busy as yourself when do
you do email
i you know i do some on the phone i do a
lot i'm very pc centric person
i sit at my desk with a nice big surface
screen
and you know i get in early to do email
a lot at night particularly if i get a
long email
i'll mark it as unread and then that
night i'm going through
the last few days looking at what i've
marked as i'm reading said okay that's
got an enclosure
let's really go through that give a
thoughtful response to it i do know if i
over schedule myself
the symptom of that is i'm i'm starting
to fall behind on email i'm not
super responsive and that you know that
can be you know a bad thing
uh you know today i got mail about you
know this coronavirus outbreak and how
you know should the foundation step up
and do something i'm you know i'm glad i
was
there to give a really quick yes
response definitely
some things are urgent and uh
but it it's a it's a gauge of of am i
imagining my schedule well that
people feel like i'm a quick quick to
reply
i discovered at an early age i didn't
think i was much good at anything
and uh but my father did bit me a big
favor he had me
working in all my spare time from the
time i was six
because he he announced he didn't want
his sons to
be country club bombs he wanted us to
feel
grateful for everything and entitled to
nothing
and and for whatever reason when you say
working he didn't give you some cushy
office job in the company no no no not
particularly at age six i started out uh
digging dandelions and when i say dig
dandelions you don't pull them out
you dig them down and you have to get
the entire route or they'll come
right back and i remember there was a
club and a swimming pool across the
street from us and i'm out there in 105
degree heat
digging these and i could hear my
friends
my little six-year-old friends they're
swimming
and jumping off the diving board and i
could recognize
each one squeal was different of joy
and i'm thinking why does my
father hate me and their fathers love
them i found out that if you don't
and then and then i of course graduated
to shoveling
out stalls and milking cows
and that doesn't sound like much work
but
it it's it's hard work so i would milk
cows before school and then again
after school milk milk or cows
and digging post holes and all these
things
but i discovered that much later
that if if you don't learn to do dirty
jobs if you don't learn
unpleasant work you by the time you're
in your 30s you never learn to work
productively and so he was doing me a
huge favor
so it was beyond the work ethic
it taught you how to work productively
and how to work with others
in mutual benefit for example if a group
of you during a dirty job
you don't try to stick it to them make
them do more then they'll try to do it
to you
and the work goes on and on you want to
work together
to get it done as efficiently as
possible you want to understand who your
customer is
how do what does my customer want what
does he value i better do this the right
way or i'll have to do it again
revolution starts in evolution
so you could have the biggest craziest
audacious
idea in the world but unless you can put
one foot in front of the other
and make that first step you're screwed
and none of it matters
and again all it does is it may allow
you to you know wrap yourself in some
really elegant rhetoric
maybe it allows you to you know be
really followed on twitter and
appear at tech conference none of that
matters
all of that crap washes out in the end
because if you suck you suck
right and you may be articulate but if
you suck it don't matter and you'll be
revealed to be a sham
what matters there is again it's just
that ability to understand
what that first specific set of things
need to be with that broader bigger goal
in mind
but if you can't put your first foot in
front of the other
and you know what's amazing most people
can't um because they get wrapped up in
the rhetoric of the vision and the
mission and all of this
you know grand deals you know blobbity
blind
that they screw up and they're their own
worst enemies i i like revolution like i
like disruption
right um but i'm skeptical that that
thing start that way i think things
let's just say ultimately five years
from now we look back and we think that
there is a massive sea change
politically
in the arab world uh because of the arab
spring
that fruit vendor is self-immolated
because he was frustrated
now maybe he started a revolution but
you know that took courage to do what he
did
that's not right or wrong in my opinion
but my point is you know
that's an example of how a revolution
started with you know a small
or not a small thing i mean it's a big
thing but um one thing that was
tractable within him
and i think these broad-based kind of
like you know
i don't know gnarly expressions of like
how all of these huge crazy things can
happen
they happen over many many many many
many years these are massive tectonic
plates
it all boils down to one person doing
one thing and i think that for a lot of
people that's hard still
you almost have to have that drop like
in other words you can't fake it you
can't like
pretend that you want to read about ted
turner and
okay i'll skip one movie your soul
yeah i mean you can fake it too you make
it in a lot of areas particularly if
you're working for somebody else but at
the end of the day
um if you're going to be created
something you've got to make the effort
to be great at something
um whether it's sports whether it's
physics
math science business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to
to learn and particularly if you're in
the technology industry because it
changes every day
you know when i got started in in
you know after i got i i got it i was a
bartender when i first came to dallas
got
into the pc industry got fired started
my own company
but there i learned early on that there
was always something new
and most people didn't put in the time
to learn it it's like now with
artificial intelligence
lots of people talk about artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
machine learning and neural networks
not a lot of people are putting in the
time to take classes or do the tutorials
or
to to learn how to apply it to business
and that's what it takes and
and you know that's just something i've
always enjoyed so that i've been
fortunate
i'm relentless i mean i'm i'm the guy
i mean i remember my first company micro
solutions
i'd buy a bucket of ribs and we we did
the system integration and i wrote
software
i'd buy a bucket of ribs and ribs i
would just eat as i would suffer as i
would
write software and i'd be there and all
of a sudden be 36 hours later
you know um or i'd lose track of days
just because i just
get so focused and so involved in it um
that that's what i do
and and and you know i still you know i
i read the hadoop manual and and
learned a little bit about pig latin and
i just want to keep up right and so
that that's probably my biggest strength
one of the things that seal
said to me and it's in in the book and
one thing that people have said that
really resonated with them
he would say that when you're when your
mind is telling you you're done
you're really only 40 done
and he had a motto if it doesn't suck we
don't do it and that was his way
of every day forcing us to get
uncomfortable
to figure out what our baseline was and
and what our you know
what our comfort level was and just you
know turning it upside down
the 40 rule maybe it's give or take a
little but look at a marathon
most people hit the wall at a marathon
at mile
anywhere from 16 to 20. and you know
99 percent of the people in this country
that run marathons finish
and they all predominantly all of them
go through this hit the wall
so where does that extra 50 or 60
percent or whatever the number is come
from i mean
it's their brain saying i'm done i don't
want to continue
but they're will saying you know what
let me get to the finish line so we
all have that will it's just a matter of
how do we apply it to
not just with the once a year marathon
but to our daily
lives and make it you know apply to
a variety of things here's the thing it
it wasn't so
so long ago that you know i was a
student
and you know sitting in a seat in an
auditorium like
uh you guys are here today listening to
i remember very specifically this time
when bill gates came to talk it
at harvard and i'm just like wow
how do you how do you do that um and
um but you know the trick is is that
the media likes to sensationalize this
as if
you have some eureka moment or you
are some singular person who can't
build something on your own and that's
just not how the world works
um you know when i was in school i built
a lot of stuff that i just liked
building
um there was not a single moment
when i when i had some revelation that
facebook was going to be
awesome that's not maybe how the media
or movies or whatever would like to
portray things it's not it's much less
exciting but
the reality is i think most uh
services in the world that reach the
scale that facebook has
um you start off building something that
you care about and
you know you don't necessarily think
it's going to be that big
i i didn't um you know i built facebook
the first version of facebook
for my college community because i
wanted to be able to connect with the
people at my school
and i remember very clearly talking to
my friends
at the time and saying you know it's how
cool is it that we have built this
community for our school
you know one day it's going to be
awesome when somebody else builds this
for the world because something like
this needs to exist for the world but
it didn't even occur to me that you know
my friends and i might
be able to play a role in doing that
right because we were college students
right i mean we didn't
have any you know engineers to to work
with or
servers or resources or anything like
that and you know there are these huge
companies that deliver products for
hundreds of millions of people right
there's i always assume that it was
going to be like microsoft
or google or uh someone would build this
for the world and
what basically just happened is um at
each step along the way we just kind of
kept
doing the next thing and uh growing from
there
and you know there were teams inside
these other companies that
that thought social media was important
and were working on it but
you know there were all these different
memes and narratives uh
in the world you know people would say
oh well you know this is just a fad
people are going to use it but then
they're going to stop so um
you know so a lot of the teams were
working on didn't take it that seriously
or
you know the the higher-ups and those
companies didn't care so they didn't get
resources and
we just kept going and going and then
people would say all right well
all right fine so maybe people are using
it but it's never going to make any
money right i mean social media doesn't
make any money then
we just kind of kept going and uh going
and then pretty soon we had a service
that was
uh bigger than any of these other ones
and that kind of
is how we are here where we are we have
a culture that's very focused
on um being very focused on what we're
building
so focus is a really important part of
it but it wasn't at google for a long
time now it seems to be in vogue so they
may be saying you know this the focus is
better but
so but at the same time we want to make
sure that everyone can come
and and add their ideas i mean some of
the best ideas throughout the the
company's evolution
they have just been from just places all
throughout the company whether it's an
engineer
or you know someone on the the customer
support team or just
different uh just different areas around
the company so we've always had
these hackathons right that are
basically time that we allocate
that the only rules that you don't work
on what you work on the rest of the time
and it's
basically an incubator for people to
prototype different ideas much in the
spirit of how facebook got founded
originally
um the idea that you can build anything
good in a day or a couple of days right
and get a version of that running
um so you get it running you then test
it internally yeah
and then we can see and that that helps
us shape the road map and what we want
to do in the future but
we also have a culture where we want to
stay very focused and um
we don't want to run with a lot of
projects that we don't expect to launch
right so um so we want to get a lot of
ideas help have those ideas shape where
we want to go
and then execute in a very focused way
on the stuff that we're going to do but
i mean
our culture i mean we have a few values
that are really important to us
and one which i talked about before is
just moving fast right the whole company
is really optimized around someone
joining being able to
build something very quickly be able to
launch it quickly iterate very quickly
on that
what is it that you understand that
makes you so successful that you think
other people
are missing i don't know
it's necessarily other people are
missing it i'm willing to do whatever it
takes
like create a a situation where it feels
like life or death
billions or body bags billions of body
banks yeah no but
in in all seriousness that i think is
the distinguishing
characteristic because all four of the
businesses
they will all turned out to be successes
but
if i didn't put it into that extra gear
i think none of them would have made it
like i i really think you have to
you have to be willing to to go all the
way
how do you pull that off though like the
first time i get it because it really is
i know you left the banking
uh you didn't exactly have a safety net
and so the first one really is sort of
billions of body bags but
after that i mean you've had some huge
wins yeah how do you recapture that
i always figured a way to put myself in
a position where
it can't not work and so you have the
first one it was not only quitting
but i also put every dollar in my bank
account into that first company did you
have kids at that point
yeah so what do you just had about that
just had a kid like the number of people
that want to be entrepreneurs that come
up to me and they say look i've got this
litany of things you know i'm married
now i have kids i can't really
do this how did you position yourself
financially
and emotionally to pull that one off i
just convinced myself that
i would do this for uh you know a year
or two give it a real go
because you had that much saved up or
the
idea was to take everything i saved
invested in the company
take a salary and then but i still
needed to raise
capital to kind of continue on and so
i hope that i'd be able to do that and
if i if i was able to then i'd
be able to sustain worst case wasn't
able to raise money
had no more money in savings and had to
go back into the workforce
did i think that i can get back in like
was i
you know past the point where of no
return and i thought
no you know i'm seven years into my
career worst case i can
go back and get it get a you know normal
job again
but it was that was too much of a safety
net no you could always go back
it was investing every penny of savings
into the business that was the real
catalyst for making sure that it worked
and then in the subsequent business it
was less about the money that was at
risk and more
friends and family money so every
relative
every friend everybody i knew pretty
much had a stake
in the startup and i just didn't want to
disappoint
all the people that i love and care
about you know but so
that drove me you talked about in
support of the 996
work routine and i've gotta underscore
to those who don't know it in particular
in china
you work nine a.m to nine pm six days a
week
and you were given a hard time because
of that and you backed off a little bit
oh 996
is the spirit that i encouraging alipapa
people
if you want to have a bright future if
you
don't want to be give up by the society
you want to be successful you have to
work hard
of course you can enjoy life you know i
work only two hours a day and
can you can you enjoy life with a 996
regime yes i do
i do do other people in shenzhen and
elsewhere i
i i think most of the people in this
world
whether the great president whether
they're good professor
we're a good engineer a good scientist a
good anchor
like you you work much more than you do
when i have a shower i think i work when
i'm the toilet
i think when i running
i think we never stop working
because today why alibaba need to 996
because we
on our side we have more than 60 million
business
rely on us if we don't work hard
they lose their hope so we have to work
hard but
but if you don't like your job
if you don't like the work you do
working two hours a day
you feel very bad if you love your jobs
people like me if i love the job i'm
doing
i love the things i'm doing 10 hours a
day
15 hours a day it's nothing i don't end
up doing things that are destructive
when i'm busy doing things that are
constructive the truth is i was never a
drug addict
i just had too much free time and made
bad choices
this planet is filled with bad choices
pornography
strip joints casinos if you were filled
up
all day long with activities if you were
addicted
to productivity if you were junkies out
on potential you wouldn't have time for
all the other garbage
i would i wouldn't be i wouldn't spend
money on stuff i don't need
when is that money spent when do we
waste most of our money on this planet
during the holidays when we have free
time
when do you spend your money when do you
go in debt on the holidays free time
so if i can just stay busy if i can use
time and create time
how do i create time i have 24 hours and
i'm like i'm a jam as much in those 24
hours as i can
and then i'll let you worry about me
burning out because that's what i'll
hear next
what about burnout when you you're gonna
burn out look i'm 60 years old
the more i do the more i can do and the
younger i get
the more i do the younger i feel the
more i do the younger my body feels
i'm not going to burn out i'm not a
candle i'm not
wax the the counselor back in in
in uh in uh the the treatment center
said to me
dude aren't you worried about because he
he's seen my success now and he's like
aren't you worried about burning out i'm
like dude you're the burnout bro you're
the burnout you're the one that said i
was gonna come back
you're the one that said i would never
make it you're the one that said
uh uh don't write books i've written
seven of them man okay
you're the one that said don't be a star
i am i have my own tv studio
right you're the one that said grant
don't get rich
just be satisfied that you don't use
drugs again no no i got rich
okay i did the rich i did the books i
did the tv
i'm going to be on a billboard i'm going
to be on a bus bro look
what are you doing i'm not worried about
burnout
i am not a candle candles burn out
spiritual beings don't so so human
beings
human beings are trapped in as spiritual
beings they're trapped
this is what i believe i believe i
believe the spiritual being is trapped
in a body
okay i believe i'm a spiritual being not
a human being the spiritual being would
have tremendous potential
unbelievable potential it would be the
light on the candle
not the candle the body would be the
candle
okay and the spiritual being would be
the flame i
i'm not i'm the flame and and i want to
see
how hot can i burn okay how far can i go
how much light can i bring the world how
much positive truth message can i
bring this planet how much more can i do
and i think the problem is people are
settling out
with just enough pay the bills take care
of my family
get my little box get my little house
put my little welcome mat
on the front put the little gate around
the yard
we're all going to be happy i don't want
the box
i don't want one location i don't need
the welcome mat i want to know the world
i want to travel the world i want to do
more
i want to be in more places i want to
have friends in every country
i want to inspire people in every
language and i want other people to see
and they can do the same thing you know
and and maybe maybe maybe at the end of
all this
i just become everybody's uncle that i
never had
this concept of time management has been
pushed off on me
my entire life and i have never ever
agreed with it i'm like why would i want
to manage
time why would i what am i going to do
how do you manage time what do i do i
like okay i'm going to watch these
seconds dude i don't want to manage time
i want to produce i want to be highly
productive i want to squeeze
time i literally want to take time and i
want to turn 60 minutes
into three hours of production that's
the different thing
that you need today not manage time
now there are some tricks when managing
time if that's where you want to come
from
like alan greenspan alan greenspan and
his roommate in college his roommate's
father
taught alan greenspan a little trick
that alan greenspan used his whole life
and it was to break up the day into 15
minute blocks
15 minutes i have something and then
fill up the next 15 minutes
now the reason alan did that and i like
that concept a lot
is because he didn't want white space on
that calendar he knew white space was a
problem
because white space nothing in the 15
minutes is a waste of time
see before you start thinking about just
managing time first i want you to do
this
number one i want you to make a list of
things that you're doing every day that
is a waste of time
that is the way you create time not
manage it
the first thing i want to do is look at
things that i'm doing that are wasteful
those two or three hours a day
that are wasteful moments things i'm
doing on facebook that just
a waste of time or maybe a game i'm
playing it's a waste of time or maybe
a newspaper i'm reading where i'm not
really learning anything i'm reading
about the
the celebrities it's a waste of time
okay second thing i want you to do is
this i want you to then start thinking
about these 15 minute blocks and filling
that calendar up but the third and most
important thing i want you to think
about is
how can you create time how can you
literally take
24 hours and and pack more into it
so that you can become more productive
so that you can use that urgency concept
and really blow up your your career blow
up your life
make the most incredible life for your
family for you
for the kids for your wife or your
husband and
for your clients so that you can take
care of yourself materially as well
my dreams are first every day then my
wife then my kids
i can take care of my wife and my kids
now would you agree i abandoned this
this is the fuel for who i am i abandon
this dream
and then i end up i can't take care of
them and then i'm gonna tell them what
it's all right that you didn't win no
it's not all right if you don't win you
need to win
how many of you need to win more okay
if you don't control your environment
folks somebody else is going to control
your environment you guys that run teams
and run organizations
if you do not control your environment
someone else will control your
environment
you are being controlled in your
environment right now cnbc
cnn msnbc the parents the kids the
twitter the facebook
the youtube the google the snapchats
or your environment your friends and
your relatives your uncles your aunts
the garbage dump called planet earth
that you live on
is mostly broken people
if you don't control your environment it
starts with
me when i was 45 years old i'm like i'm
going to control
my environment i'm going to take every
penny i have all the energy i have
all the resources i have and i'm going
to improve me
if i got to go broke in the process
because i'm already broke
look if you're not fulfilled to your if
you're not reaching your full potential
every day
you're broke right now i come in today i
i walk
you know i we we fly into london uh we
get here 11 15.
i i don't know what i'm going to do next
there's 5 000 people out there
somebody sends me a text okay this is
what your day looks like okay now now i
start
i start running and hustling from one
thing to the next thing
in between what i'm going to do is i'm
going to jam i'm going to jam
stuff in between events so that i leave
this
i'm going to be here eight or nine hours
i'm going to leave this and it's going
to feel like i was here eight days
and so i'm going to jam as much in so i
don't get in trouble because the more
active i am
i'm creating time basically i'm not
trying to manage time
i'm not trying to manage my day i'm
trying to create my day
yeah so i i look at everything as like
i'm creating something
i'm creating always in creation because
that keeps me from being effect
so i'm either going to be pushing this
thing or it's going to be pushing on me
and um you know i'm not
look i don't fly the plane i can only
push as much as my skills allow me to
yeah so
i can tell the guys from the back hey
guys get up give us a good
straight landing right down the middle
okay get us a little faster give us a
little higher but i'm just bull
from the back because i can't fly the
plane you know
i'm in the back i'm in the back of the
plane you guys are doing great up there
right okay so so keep it straight when
you land
right don't wreck this thing don't
damage it right i'm just [ __ ] from
the back
yeah you guys you guys autopilot that's
all y'all do up there
right so so uh you know i i make this
joke about pilots i'm like anybody can
fly a plane not anybody
not not just anyone can buy a plane yeah
right
but it it it's a it's a kind of
tongue-in-cheek thing
because i can't fly a plane so it
doesn't matter how much
i want to i can't so i can't micromanage
that
but what i can do when i'm on the plane
like last night we got on at 10 o'clock
got to the airport at 9 45 walked on the
plane beds are made
two kids a nanny elena all have our
little separate beds
bam we knock out we wake up at 11 15
this morning
here so i'm refreshed ready to go and
then somebody sends me a little thing
that says this is what you're doing
today first you got rob moore
i said oh god damn that dude
okay so then we'll bang bang bang bang
and then we're gonna leave out uh here
about nine o'clock tonight
go to dubai and do that all over again
so
that's how every day works okay except
for today when i woke up here
some somewhere this morning somebody
when they wake up is gonna send me the
first thing that happens to me every
morning is i get a cash account
yeah every single day yeah so i i say
okay
okay nobody's stealing from me okay
those numbers are getting bigger
okay that one went down okay i know this
money's going here i need money man i
got
i'm playing chess those are my pieces
and if i didn't have money it would be
okay what's my time
it's either money or time which one am i
which one am i running i would rather
fast than perfect
yeah i would rather i'd rather i'll post
something that's got grammatical uh
issues the first book i ever wrote had
hundreds of misspelled words not a few
hundreds of them
and a guy i remember a guy first person
told me about him i didn't see him
i wrote it it wasn't a ghost writer i
wrote the book
bang bang bang bang so um
the guy calls me says man you've got
hundreds of misspelled words i i have a
spreadsheet he's trying to be of service
to me he's like he sends me a
spreadsheet
grammar choline semicolon i use
semicolons where there should be colons
uh commas where there should be periods
and he's like run on sentences
and and he sends me this whole
spreadsheet like 40 pages
of corrections i said man thanks for
doing that
yeah i mean he's like i just want to be
sure you get it right i said bro it's a
best-selling book
it's a best-selling book
and he's like huh i said it's a
best-seller son
it's not a best written yeah it ain't a
perfect grammar book
like i've never been perfect i'm sloppy
i'm i'm i'm you know i'm i push hard i
push
fast but i'd rather i'd rather you know
i remember bill gates bill gates says
look if
if microsoft can't be the best let's
make it look like it's the best
you know when china was ripping bill off
he's like if they're going to rip
somebody off
let's make sure they rip off microsoft
like the attitude is like
get to the market you know get to the
market be in the market put in
put it in people's hands we can fix it
later if you look at if you look at the
the this little device right here they
came out with an 11.
the 11 had so many bugs in it every day
people were getting
you've been updated updated his code for
phone was and we had to push it out
because we want to hit our quarter we
want to keep people excited with new
products
so we're willing to hit people with a
new product that's got bugs in it
now the perfectionist says no no we need
to wait okay we got to get it
perfect we got to get it fixed which
means you're going to get slaughtered in
the marketplace
by a beast that runs faster
and dominates the market and overwhelms
the customer
with new products uh while you're
sitting back in your laboratory saying
hey we're going to make it perfect
that goes for the artist to the
businessman to the musician to everyone
to the to the this is why men have an
advantage in social media over women
because women got to do the filter got
to fix their hair
got to do their makeup oh bodybuilding
world champions
he's got to go pump first yeah yeah tie
ties back there tyler
he's back there ty's a friend of mine
he's back there pumping up right now
he's trying to get his pack swollen
you know so so like like you what you
watch my social media
like like most of it's not planned not
90
of it's not planned i have bad hair days
i say the wrong things i want to push
the i want to push product out i want to
get i'd rather frequency frequency and
speed
over quality and i'll figure the quality
out as i go
elena she has a very very magical kind
of like
think okay she she's not stuck in
mechanics
and this is something that everybody
should
um try
try to understand if you're if you're
running something
if you're going to do something big you
cannot get lost in mechanics
mechanics is how much does it weigh how
far does
it have to be carried who's going to
carry it
how long is it going to take it's all
that pickup the weight
the heaviness of of an activity i'm a
doer i'm
i dig holes like you tell me what to do
i go to the gym i work out every day
like it's effort
so i'm an effort i'm in the f that
effort band that push
uh the force in different places
in life i promise you you're gonna find
you don't know where to go everybody
goes through this the most successful
people in the world
wake up some mornings with no clue
what to do today okay so first thing i
want you to know is that it's normal it
happens to everybody it's not like
you're a bad person or you're lost or
you're depressed or
you you got some problem you need to
take medication for
everybody everybody regardless their
stature in life where they
are regardless of their money their
relationship
their job they run the joint
promise you no matter how much they
present
like they look like they got the whole
package put together everybody
everybody has those days
and the sun is kicking today has those
days
where uh they don't know what to do
i don't know what to do you know
uncertainty my friend dale christensen
told me when i was
25 years old i was experiencing
depression every day he's like
no matter what man no matter what
no matter what dude show up even if your
eyes are bleeding
show up i've been doing that for 34
years now
show up even when i don't want to okay
and then what i try to do is i try to
help
one person one person
and what happened over the period of 34
years i did that every day
i'm not depressed anymore at least not
for long periods of time
i don't use any kind of medication don't
use any kind of drugs don't smoke weed
don't drink over
excessively drink i might have a drink
once in a while
and got a beautiful wife two beautiful
kids and for the most part my life is
freaking wonderful
all i did was this i don't over analyze
never do i label myself a loser a
quitter
um i'm hard on myself
i never i never label myself ocd
acd add ocdd
whatever a depressant uh alcohol like a
drug addict no no i don't
this is what i do i do things okay i
show up move in the direction
i don't over analyze move in the
direction that that i think could be
more pro-survival than staying in one
place and number three
help somebody anybody if you ask me to
coach your business
i'm not going to think about how to hold
on to what you did last year that's what
most people right now are thinking here
in march
in january you're like this is going to
be a great year by march you're like
man i just want to do what we did last
year if we just do you're starting to
make sense you're becoming reasonable
okay i'm telling you that because this
is what your people do too
okay your people the people that you
hire they make sense of how to make 48
grand a year
and if you have people in your company
they're trying to make sense of how to
make 48 grand a year you've got a
company that's going to die
toys r us file bankruptcy this week i
heart radio the biggest radio
station in the world filed for
bankruptcy this week
there's going to be massive disruption
in the marketplace why because these
companies thought about
they they kept they kept having trophies
about what they had
rather than what what they could get
who's got money
who's qualified to buy how can i get
their attention
how can i tell them what i want from
them okay
how fast can i get to the marketplace
fast speed
is the new big make decisions quickly
so that i can sell things quickly
because if you do it if you do it
if you do it a certain way you give
yourself permission to ask
other people to do the same thing
it's built in ethics at the end of the
last year on december the
13th or 14th captain ryan's in a row
[Music]
i said dude we're going to buy a plane
by the end of the year
okay okay i'm gonna wipe out my tax bill
i'm gonna buy a damn plane and we're
gonna wipe it out okay i bought a plane
in less than
nine days brand new plane in nine days
the guy gulfstream says dude nobody does
this most people take nine months some
people take nine years
they nine days we bought the plane
bought it chopped it bought it closed it
he's like nobody does that it's
ridiculous huge purchase big purchase
typically a very long cycle a lot of a
lot of shopping
i guarantee you that decision that
quickly would make me a lot of money
you understand why that's how i make
decisions man so what do i expect you
guys to make decisions the same way i
spent 50 million bucks
in freaking 90 minutes and you guys take
freaking nine months to spend six grand
make decisions quick make decisions as
fast as you can stay certain you can get
new money
everybody agree see when i do that in my
own life i can press you to do the same
thing
i've given myself permission and in this
universe giving myself permission
to push people to do things faster if
you take a
long time to do things
[Music]
your buyer will then be allowed to take
a long time to do things you shop a
second place a third place
a fourth place a fifth place a sixth
place guess what
they will too you gotta get a best deal
because your daddy taught you to get a
good deal
never be taken advantage of shop two and
three places
get your best discount it's gotta be on
sale
then guess what every customer you have
is going to what
give me a deal man give me a deal man
give me a deal man okay
your worst customers are the ones you
give the best deal to
[Applause]
never can make them happy they want
something oh give me something extra
give me something else the mooch
never satisfied right or wrong because
you guys are mooches
[Applause]
you guys are mooches just be honest man
you can't fix what you deny
you're a mooch they're going to be a
mooch they're cheap they're going to be
cheap you're cheap they're going to be
cheap you take a long time they're going
to take a long time
you shop four or five places they're
going to do the same thing you need more
information they're going to do the same
thing
you got to have your wife involved
they're going to do the same thing
if you're going to make mistakes in your
life make them fast
right if you're going to lose a deal
make them lose the deal fast if you're
not going to make any money on the deal
make sure the deal is quick right how
many made no money on a deal this month
but it took four hours that's stupid man
you see most of you in a room
unfortunately you listen to the media so
much
you think you're you think you're you're
everything's good you think you're fine
okay because the media has not exposed
the reality
on the middle class they talk about
poverty and they talk about the rich
people and they never talk about the
people in between
the people in between in this country
suffer more than the
people in poverty people in poverty are
actually taken care of people in the
middle
are completely ignored i'm talking about
the people that make 200 grand a year
and live up here and still don't have
any money left over they send their kids
to school they got two bmws
they live in a nice house they have air
conditioned water and heat
right and there's no money so they send
a little bit of money to a keo account
and they think okay we're going to
retire one day you're going to be old
one day
by the time you get to use that money
you'll be so old you won't want to use
it
the only thing that's going to change
anything for you and your family is like
hey man what am i doing here okay
you don't need to go work in another
industry you take the habits you have
right now to the restaurant business the
restaurant business will fail every
business is in disruption right now
everything you change you want to go do
you want to go trade bitcoin it's going
to take a commitment
it's going to take ups and downs going
to be a bunch ups and downs in that
crypto play everybody agree
yeah okay you want to go do the real
estate game rather than a card game
i'ma tell you something right now man if
you don't bring commitment and
discipline
and and and fortitude and persistence to
the real estate
game you will get killed in the real
estate game there's no game that you're
gonna win at
that doesn't require a commitment i've
been lost most of my life literally the
first 45 years of my life
the first probably 51 years of my life
first 45 years for sure i was completely
lost
and uh somewhere between 45 and 51 i
started figuring out okay what am i
doing i started sorting my life out i
started getting some
i started doing some courses that really
really made a difference in my life
i've always been in a self-improvement
my whole life
and but it wasn't until i was about 45
that i really started discovering
information that could make me more
confident
me more sure you know when i was 25
years old i was a young sales person and
i didn't like sales and
and i got educated on how to sell and i
became very
very good at it um i started
understanding the process the customer
the objections the rebuttals how to
follow up how to handle the rejection
and the disappointment to discourage how
to get over it but that didn't help me
become
more confident in me as a person as an
individual i was making money
by the time i was 31 i had a couple
businesses
they were making money probably had you
know
three four hundred thousand dollars
saved when i was 30 31 years old
because i was trying to make a little
money right by the time i'm 33 i got a
probably a million dollars in a bank i
still didn't feel good about myself
i had this nagging nagging like
sense of desperation anxieties
depression
uncertainty a lack of confidence
and
when i started working on me spiritually
that's that's when
that's when at 45 46 47 years old that's
when everything changed for me
like everything all the expansion the
the confidence the getting out in the
world the
maybe a little better communicating than
i was doing i'm not perfect at it by any
means now
and i started getting more certainty
about who i am what i am
where i'm going and why i'm here like if
you don't figure those things out no
amount of money no amount of money in
the world will
will fill you up no the private planes
won't the fancy cars
you have to know where you're going now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
i'm gonna go away counterculture on this
one
i don't think you need to beat the stun
up to have success
what matters is that you're productive
that you get results
that you stop wasting time too many
people default to thinking that if they
just wake up an hour earlier they're
going to be way more productive
if you're not productive in a 16-hour
day what makes you think that you're
gonna be
more productive in a 17-hour day when
you have less sleep
so this is a interesting message in
timing for me right now because
i i love beating the sun up i love it i
love
working i like my default state if nina
is
off on a friday night with her friends
or something 80
chance i'm working i love it i look
forward to it when i go close my eyes i
can't wait for it to be the next day
like i'm pumped to go off and do the
work i recently did a sleep study
and my doctor was concerned i wasn't
getting enough quality sleep so i went
to go do a sleep study
and the doctor after going through the
results
told me that i need to be sleeping eight
and a half hours to nine hours a night
and it and it like super disappointed me
eight and a half hours to nine hours are
you kidding me i i'm trying to go from
i was trying to go from eight to seven i
was waking up after eight hours sleep
and and feeling still a little bit tired
and so that's why my doctor recommended
even going to the sleep study
and i'm trying to figure out how do i
hack it to get down to seven and still
be fully functional not
not be you know lazy and slow and not
having my cognition
and uh yeah he said i need to be
sleeping eight and a half to nine hours
a night he said is that
is that normal like are you not worried
like no as long as you're under 10 it's
normal
people range from six to ten and they're
totally fine like this
sucks i mean i'm not happy about it i'm
still looking at how can i
hack my sleep more and we've tried a lot
i have the chili pad
we've got you know meditation before
sleeping i'm lying on the bed of
nails with the thing behind me the
pillow the nail pillow
no you know phones or computers x amount
of time before going to bed
red light filters on everything red
lights no lights at all in the place
right like just these real
red lights going around after sunrise
after sunset
lots of it cool down the temperature i
don't know all of it don't eat past
eight o'clock no caffeine past two
o'clock all of it i'm doing all of that
stuff
all of it right plus probably a lot more
stuff
i've i've studied and hacked away i
still believe there's a lot more hacking
i still want to get it from nine to
seven but but if i'm at nine and i need
nine
i think you should get nine i'm at the
point now where if i wake up and the sun
is still
uh not up i stay in bed and and that's
actually
uh boosting of confidence it's like okay
so i wake up and sun
hasn't come up yet okay this is hard
this is difficult it's difficult for me
to not get out of bed
i'm gonna stay in bed just because now
i'm i'm uh i'm a weird duck
so maybe this works for you maybe it
doesn't but i was having a great
conversation with uh jeremy who's on my
team who
i've invested in his business he's
helping companies scale their youtube
channels
and he was going through the same thing
where he was feeling a little tired in
the afternoon
he wanted to nap on some afternoons and
that's never been me so dude you need to
just try uh waking up without an alarm
and he normally he's up at 4 30 in the
morning or something um
so just wake up without an alarm and see
how it goes and he ended up sleeping for
nine hours
and hated hating himself for doing it
it's like dude maybe you need nine hours
like much more important than that extra
hour or two is what are you doing during
the day
if if you're losing energy during the
day and you want to nap every afternoon
you're not being productive like there's
no way
sleep and be productive you need sleep
to win
i think everybody should get a sleep
test i think it's a brutal experience
you don't you barely sleep right when
you're there you got stuff up your nose
and a million centers all over you
but to know how much sleep you actually
need uh and making sure that you're
productive
during the time that you are awake
that's the most important thing that you
are productive
during the time that you are awake is
way more important than if you wake up
before the sun gets up
okay so how can you do it i'm going to
give you a three-step process that i
think will help
step number one is fix your calendar fix
your calendar you got to make sure that
you're productive make sure your actions
map to your admissions the reason
why so many people say wake up early is
because
your evening hours for many people are
not productive because when you wake up
you're more likely to be productive and
you're gonna you're gonna do your work
you're gonna get on your morning routine
you're gonna feel like you've got a kick
start on the day you're going to go off
and start to crush it
where if you're staying up late at night
you're going to find yourself playing
games or watching netflix you're doing
things that aren't productive right
like waking hours make sure you're
productive
put it in your calendar you're waking up
around this time right
how are you going to spend your morning
routine what does that look like and
then what are you going to do
and mapping it out so that when you can
step above your calendar and look at the
week and the month that's ahead you say
if i did these things that's in my
calendar
i'm going to be more successful i'm
going to be closing in on my goals right
your actions map to your ambitions
so you create your calendar and then you
go and live it
and then you go and do it the most
important thing again isn't
making sure you're up before the sun
it's making sure that you're doing the
things that you said you were going to
do
and the things that you said you were
going to do are going to lead you to
accomplishing the success that you want
to have
you have to be more productive and fix
your calendar step number two is
understand how much sleep you actually
need
right i i've heard it i guess before but
i didn't really buy it until i went and
did the sleep study
and again i'm still trying to hack it i
still believe i can get it lower
even if i go from nine to eight that's
amazing
but i have to be fully refreshed i have
to be ready to start my day and so
understand how much sleep you need right
here's a challenge
for tomorrow don't set an alarm and see
what time you wake up
and if and you sleep an extra hour and
you feel more refreshed
like you're probably living in a massive
sleep deficit
for you and so maybe you need seven
hours or maybe you need eight hours or
maybe you need nine hours
and if you need a lot more than that
then maybe you know
there's a problem you gotta go get it
fixed i was hoping that he could give me
uh
like if i had sleep apnea amazing my
problem with sleep apnea awesome give me
the machine i'll sleep with every night
i'll sleep seven hours and i'll go and
crush it's like no you don't have sleep
apnea
you don't you don't have any
deficiencies i did a bunch of blood
tests no deficiencies there's nothing
actually wrong with you you just need
nine hours sleep it just tears me apart
but you have to figure out how much
sleep you need because again sacrificing
one hour of sleep
and being tired all day is not going to
make you more productive
understand how much sleep you need and
then factor that into your calendar
factor that into your life so you can be
happy you can be fulfilled you can have
energy you can go and crush your goals
and then step number three is work to
your rhythm some people work better at
night than they do during the day
right again as i said earlier the reason
why so many people advocate for
a morning start is because at night
most people aren't productive at night
you're losing time at night you're
watching netflix and playing games and
doing things that aren't in supportive
of your mission right
listen to grant though he goes to sleep
at nine greco don't go sleep at night
and he wakes up before the sun comes up
he's getting enough sleep to do it
right but your best productivity might
be at nine like maybe you don't even
turn on until nine maybe you should be
working
from nine until four in the morning
right
work to your style because if you try to
be somebody else and you try to work to
a different style that's not suited for
you you're not going to win
it's more difficult if you're working
from 9 00 you know p.m to 4 a.m
how many hours is that 10 11 12 that's
seven hours
right if you're working from nine to
five the other way
uh that's gonna be hard to do meetings
it's gonna be hard to have team calls
it's gonna be hard to
scale up your business right it'll be
difficult because most people don't
wanna work
for a midnight meeting with you but if
that's where you
are your most creative and that's where
you get the most productivity out of you
then you need to factor that in if
you're more of an night owl and you're
going to work
every night you're going to move forward
on your ambitions every night
then don't beat yourself up because you
didn't get up before the sun came up
stop
trying to be perfect one of the biggest
things that holds entrepreneurs back
is you have an idea in your head and you
want to launch it but you're afraid to
launch anything until it's perfect
you're afraid to put anything out into
the world
until you have the perfect plan the
perfect product the perfect competitive
advantage and that does not
exist and the biggest danger of all is
that just stays an idea for you
for the rest of your life that it never
actually gets created
because you can never reach perfection
because you're afraid of releasing the
thing
out into the world and so you never will
where everybody who you look up to the
people who've had massive success any
entrepreneur
they released something before it was
perfect
they got feedback they adjusted they
listened to it
and that became the thing that propelled
them to massive success
and so you need to move from that place
of trying to have everything be a
hundred percent perfect before you
launch
and just get used to actually creating
actually doing actually putting stuff
out there into the market
instead of sitting on your couch hoping
wishing dreaming
planning strategizing but never actually
doing
i like having dedicated days to do
dedicated things so you know i film once
a month
for my youtube channel for the most part
and we come in on a wednesday
and film everything in one sitting
and i mean i'm in video mode i find it
really hard to switch tasks
i think most people do but i just find
it really hard i can't go from
meeting with somebody for half an hour
to then writing a book
for half an hour to then getting on a
phone call for half an hour to then
record the video for half an hour i just
the switching costs are too high if i'm
gonna write my book
or do something else that's really
creative i need half an hour to 40
minutes just to get into it
before i'm actually really creating
something good it's why when i make my
videos here i start with the easy stuff
first
and then i lead to the espressos because
it allows me to warm up
to get going if i had to come in and
boom just drop it in espresso it would
be a lot
more challenging for me and so anything
you do multiple times per week
try to do months per week multiple times
per month once per month and so on more
times per day once per day
right like email social media if you're
doing that
all day long do that once per day it
means that you miss out on some small
things
it means that you miss out on getting
some opportunities maybe some reporter
wants to interview you and has a
deadline by 3 p.m today
and you don't open that email till 5
o'clock you've missed it
but you have to be willing to let go of
the little to be able to go for the big
and i used to pride myself as the guy
who responded to email
super fast you sent me an email like two
minutes later boom response i would drop
whatever i was doing
to respond to your email and what it
meant was i was doing
lots of little tasks really quickly but
i never got to focus on the big task
because they kept getting distracted
and so by chunking your time and by
blocking off access in your calendar
it means you'll have to say no to
something some little project some
things will slip through
but you're spending your time on the big
projects that matter and so it's been
probably the single most important time
management
skill practice that i've applied is
chunking your time
having one main thing that i do every
single day
so you know wednesday is recording
youtube videos and when i'm not doing
that it's my lilly day
we're looking at her channel thursday's
night public facing day
and we're doing interviews and podcasts
and radio shows and youtube channels and
just
extrovert mode monday is my tds day so
i'm here i'm working with alex we're
working through all the problems that we
have to do with tds looking at
opportunities where we're going to grow
i'm just in
tds mindset right so every day i'm doing
something else
but it also means i i will delay
something so
if it's something tds related and alex
send it to me on tuesday
i'm probably not going to get it to next
monday and so part of that is training
the team to say hey
we gotta get it done on time so i can
handle it at the right moment
but also means that sometimes we may
miss windows of opportunities
because i haven't seen it but not it's
not going to come up again till monday
and being okay with that being okay with
dropping some small balls
so you can keep the big ones in the air
eliminate automate delegate
so take a good look at what you're doing
and how many of them
should you not even do it at all right i
mean the whole idea is here we need to
free up your time to work on the things
that are actually worth
you working on and part of that is i
need to stop
doing things completely there are some
things that you are doing right now that
you shouldn't even be doing
nobody should be doing in you it's just
not valuable to your business or to your
life goals you've been doing it because
maybe it used to work
you've been doing it because it was a
great idea great but you shouldn't do it
anymore
you need to eliminate it take take a
good look at your calendar because if
you're spending your time
doing work i i believe you have michael
jordan level talent right i believe you
you could be the greatest in the world
that's something
but you're only spending two to five
percent of your time actually on what
you have michael jordan level talent at
and the rest of your time the chunk of
your time the bulkier time
on stuff that you don't even like to do
that you have no ambitions to be great
at
and so can you eliminate just completely
eliminate some of those tasks
then it's automate so the tasks that are
left okay what can be automated
they have to get done but do they have
to get done by a person if not
is there software are there tools that
you can use to help you make that
process smoother
and then the last part is delegate so
now we've taken tasks that have to be
done right we haven't eliminated them
can't be done by automation software
robots
have to be done by a person then is it
you like are you the person
that should be doing it or should it be
somebody else my goal here is we need to
free up your time to focus on the things
that you could be world class
at because if you're spending your time
doing stuff that you don't like and that
you're not good at you're never going to
go off and accomplish
the goals that you have and build the
life that you want to build if you want
to sign up for the entire billionaire
mindset series for free and get the
companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there